one of the essentials of citizenship is
a presence of the creation and the
preservation of a large middle class
[Music]
this idea goes all the way back to
greece where citizenship first developed
and they had a word for it the mesoi
m-e-s-o-i
and their way of thinking you had to
have the majority of citizens
self-employed
independent
outspoken and neither rich nor poor the
middle class alone were neither
dependent on the state
nor
did they emulate or did they envy the
rich
and so these mesoi and the idealized
greek city-state were the citizens that
showed up in the assembly hall they were
outside
and they had an equal seat on
stone benches that equality was
reflected in the military sense by slots
and the phalanx that is the armed
squares
of spearmen that fought
the battles of the city-state
and finally there was a third dimension
of the middle class and that was the
agrarian grid outside the city-state
most land was parceled as it was during
the homestead act in the united states
into 10-acre parcels the citizen also
had to be independent they were in
control of the laws they made the laws
and they were not subject to coercion
from the poor or the rich there's
another idea that comes from the ancient
world that's important to remember
that
something about
being
in charge of your own destiny combines
the mental with the physical
and by that i mean in the pre-industrial
world most people were farmers
so they would get up in the morning
and they would prune vines
or they would have to plant olive trees
or in the spring they would cut grain or
thresh it but it was a constant physical
job
but yet they were making decisions it
was a mental task and to the greeks this
combination of mental acuity and
physical strength made the perfect
balance now we all can't be
farmers today only one percent of the
nation farms but we have all of these
tasks today the independent trucker
think about it he has to have endurance
to get on that highway for 16 17 hours
but yet he has to make the decisions
which job should i take how much is
diesel fuel cost and the same thing
holds true of the business person
if you work for a corporation you make
very important decisions but the
independent business person
is responsible for his own destiny or
her destiny
and one mistake can destroy their family
they're not a cog in a corporate wheel
so what i'm suggesting to you is
maybe we can't be all small farmers or
we can't be all middle class small
business people but we need this group
to be present
because without this present you do not
have these independent voices and we
don't combine the physical and the
mental and of people who take
responsibility for themselves
okay so middle-class citizenship is
crucial in the history of constitutional
government unfortunately in our
generation it's eroding and we can see
it erode in a variety of contexts the
first is for 10 years average wages of
the middle class did not rise 50 percent
of the country
dies with less than ten thousand in
aggregate wealth over half of americans
die with credit card debt
their buying options are limited
their choices on how they live are
limited their chances at home ownership
decline
simply because they owe a lot of debt
nowhere is this more dramatic than in
student loans when the student graduates
the average loan is somewhere between 30
and 40 thousand dollars we have an
entire generation of students
that are graduating often with
therapeutic degrees and are not able to
find jobs that would allow them to pay
off this enormous debt if we came from
mars and we looked at the situation we
would just simply say you have tens of
thousands of serfs or indentured
servants if they're not beholden to
their credit cards
they're beholden to the federal
government and the universities
[Music]
you